-Welcome, everybody. Welcome t
"The Tonight Show."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Today, NBC announced
that it will not air
next year's Golden Globes
due to the
controversy surrounding
the Hollywood
Foreign Press Association.
Yeah, it's like NBC said to ABC,
"We see your hostless award show
and raise you no award show.
No award show."
That's right.
The group has been under fir
for its finances,
its lack of diversity,
and press conferences filled
with sexism, racism,
and homophobia.
It's never good
when you check every box
in a human resources video
It's like, "Yeah, yeah,
we did that, too.
Yeah, we definitely did that."
Meanwhile, Fox News
heard all of that and was like
"We'll host it."
NBC put their foot down.
You know you have
a problem with diversity
when you're called out by
the same network
that made "Friends."
You know what I'm saying?
This means the
new standard-bearer
for international acclaim is
the Nickelodeon
Kids' Choice Awards blimp, so...
Another big story is
the scandal in horse racing.
It just came out that
Medina Spirit,
the horse that won
last weekend's Kentucky Derby,
tested positive for steroids
after the race.
When he heard that,
the horse was like,
"Hey, you said that needle was
the third Pfizer vaccine."
I think the
real giveaway was when
he ran the race on two legs.
Jockey on his shoulders.
[ Drumsticks clacking ]
-[ Imitates fanfare ]
-Right now,
the horse is thinking,
"As long as I'm
being putting out to stud,
this sounds more like
a you problem."
As if things weren't bad enoug
for Medina Spirit,
a photo just surfaced of him
partying with Jeffrey Epstein.
-Oh, my God.
-Can you believe...
-Just terrible, terrible week.
-Awful, awful.
-Terrible week for horse racing.
Yeah, his racing days may be
over, but on the bright side
he just joined the
Russian gymnastics team.
That's unbelievable.
Meanwhile, even former
President Trump weighed in
He released a statement,
writing...
That's his blog.
Can we zoom in to the phot
of Trump there?
I just can't stop laughing
at the image of him
at his desk writing about hi
thoughts about a horse by hand
"This is a disgrace."
-[ As Trump ] Done.
You guys hear about this
over the weekend?
A major pipeline that runs
from Texas to New Jersey
had to be shut down
due to a cyberattack.
-Ooh!
-We don't know who did it,
but the message just said...
Today, the pipeline operator
says it plans to
resume service
by the end of this week.
Verizon heard
and was like, "Come on.
Even we can
do better than that."
Meanwhile, I read that
the prices of everyday items
have been skyrocketing
recently due to shortages.
It has a lot of people worried
And I agree
prices are getting way too high.
Did you see this earlier today
Take a look.
-Oatmeal --
actual retail price...
-Wow. See what I'm saying?
For oatmeal.
-"Showcase Showdown" is
coming up next, folks.
-For oatmeal.
Can you believe that?
That's insane for oatmeal.
-Wow! That seems pretty steep.
-On to some good news.
Dr. Fauci said that, soon,
it may be time
to relax indoor mask rules
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's right.
Fauci also said he thinks
we'll be back to normal
by Mother's Day 2022.
I'm guessing that's what
he told his wife yesterday
when she said, "Why are we not
going out to brunch?"
He's like, "Uh...is that today
Mother's Day? Of course.
[ Laughs nervously ]
What?"
And today, British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson
announced that,
starting next week,
cautious hugging
will be allowed in England
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yep, cautious hugging, or,
as people in England call it -
[ English accent ]
Oh, normal hugging.
Hello. Good night.
Alright, everyone go to bed.
Very good. Oh, hello.
That's right.
Alright, there --"
-"Daddy loves you."
-Daddy loves you.
Now go back -- Off to bed.
That's that.
We did that.
Get this -- computer scientist
say that they've created
artificial intelligence that
can detect sarcasm.
-Oh!
-Yep, computers
that actually know sarcasm
That's amazing.
And it got me thinking,
hey, Siri, do you know sarcasm
-No, Jimmy,
I don't know sarcasm.
Now get back to your monologue
I really want to hear more o
your great jokes about horses.
-Wow!
-Hang on.
If I didn't know any better,
I'd say that was sarcasm.
-Wow. Nothing gets by you,
Sherlock Holmes.
-Come on, I thought we had
a good relationship.
-Yeah, I love being asked abou
the weather 900 times a day.
There's no way
you could look out a windo
and figure it out
for your [bleep] self.
-Okay, you know, that's enough
-Hey!
-Just stop. Turn it off.
-Turn it off.
Turn it off.
-Indeed.
-Hey, I saw that
a small sketch of a bear
drawn by Leonardo da Vinci
could sell for more
than $16 million at auction.
Yeah. I don't mean
to knock da Vinci,
but are we sure that's a bear?
Do you see this?
It looks like the logo
for Boar's Head cold cuts.
-[ Laughing ] Wow!
-And get this -- I read that
over 800 turtles
were just rescued from storm
drains along the Jersey shore.
-Aww!
-That's the good news.
The bad news is, it's now
Turtlefest at Red Lobster.
This is just unbelievable.
It's just --
-Awful.
-Why would they do that?
-Terrible.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Experts say that they're babies
and they'll be okay.
It's when they're raised in th
sewer and become teenagers
that you have to worry.
Then, Splinter,
the rat, was like,
"Hey, by the way,
did you know I was originall
drawn by da Vinci?"
Did you know that?
-I did not know that.
-Yeah, da Vinci did it.
Finally, I saw that
Dartmouth University's
medical school is
accusing 17 students
of cheating on remote tests.
When they heard, 50 millio
students learning remotely
were like,
"Who would do such a thing?"
One of the accused student
said, "I swear I didn't cheat.
From the bottom of my heart...
which is a muscular organ
that pumps blood
through the circulatory system."
♪♪♪♪
Today President Biden met
with six state governors
to discuss ways that they ca
get more Americans vaccinated.
Yep, they spent about 15 minutes
coming up with ideas
and three hours talking
about if Bennifer is back.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
That's right,
Biden needed more ideas
after Dr. Fauci refused to pos
for a shirtless calendar.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He said no.
It's crazy that this
is still a problem.
I mean, even COVID is thinking
"I can't believe
I'm re-signing my lease.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't think I could get
the deposit back."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not sure what incentives
to get vaccinated are left
I mean, so far, we tried food,
alcohol, drugs, gift cards
sports tickets, money.
Pretty much just leaves sex,
doesn't it?
I mean, is that
where we're going?
[ Laughter ]
-Aah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-No, no, I'm not doing that.
No, no, no, no, I'm not.
[ The Roots playing funk ]
No, no, no, absolutely, no, no
-Oh, dear.
-No, I really -- no.
Get vaccinated, everybody,
just please.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Sultry voice ] Get the shot
[ Laughter ]
-That's right,
the government is doing
all they can
to get people vaccinated.
Today, I read that the Biden
administration is teaming up
with McDonald's to help rais
vaccine awareness.
Yep, so get ready
for the all-new
McDerna.
It's going to be good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoa, awesome!
-You know we're living
through historic times
when McDonald's is giving public
health advice, don't you think
[ Laughter ]
Yep, McDonald's is even
putting up a billboard
in Times Square that says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Also, as long as McDonald'
is working to fight disease,
they might want to look
into whatever this thing was
I have no idea.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Aww.
-Well, here in New York City
it was just announced
that some subway stations
are offering COVID vaccines.
Yeah, first,
they sterilize your arm
with a $2 bottle of vodka
in a paper bag that was left
in the seat,
then, they hold the shot
near your arm
and a parkour dancer
kicks it in.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's going to be amazing.
This is actually cool --
they even got the MTA announce
to list all of the side effects.
"Fever, headaches,
soreness, sweating."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, over in Italy,
a nurse accidentally
gave a woman
six doses of the Pfizer
vaccine in one shot.
[ Laughter ]
I think, in Italy,
they call that
family-style.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Six doses of the vaccine.
I'm 99% sure this is how every
Marvel movie starts, isn't it?
"Save us, Captain Pfizer!"
[ Laughter ]
At this point,
she's now protected
from COVID-19,
-20, -21, -22...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, just when we thought
we made it
through the worst
of the pandemic,
the next big threat
to public health has arrived
-Starbucks is launching
the strawberry funnel cake
frappuccino.
[ Laughter ]
It has as many calories
as a double cheeseburger
at McDonald's.
It's a blend of strawberry purée
and whipped cream
with funnel cake pieces
and powdered sugar.
[ Laughter ]
-If you want one,
just walk in and say,
"Venti diabeté."
[ Laughter ]
You know someone's going
to be like,
"I'll take
a funnel cake frappuccino,
but can I get it
with skim milk?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Hushed ]
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
I saw that ABC just renewe
"Grey's Anatomy"
for an 18th season.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh.
-Even the cicadas
coming back are like,
"This show is still on?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, I saw that
the cost of wood is increasing
which is making toilet paper
more expensive.
Maybe that's why Dr. Fauci
was like,
"Well, let's not throw out
those face masks just yet.
♪♪♪♪
Well, everyone's heard
about the pipeline hack.
And people are actually
making it worse by freaking ou
and panic-buying gas.
And now thousands
of gas stations are out of fuel.
See, this probably explain
why my Uber driver
gave me a piggy-back to 30 Rock.
[ Laughter ]
A gas shortage --
Right now, there's probabl
a guy who just got home
like, "Honey, throw away
all the toilet paper.
We got to clear space
for gasoline.
We got to do it --"
"Honey, are you okay?"
[ Laughter ]
People are panic-buying gas.
And one couple stocking up
went viral today.
Look at this.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
They drove about 8 feet before
they passed out from the fumes
[ Laughter ]
And that was a minivan, too,
so you know there are kids
involved.
"Should we roll down
the windows?
Hunter looks sleepy, hon."
[ Laughter ]
Well, at least they used
proper containers.
Listen to what other peopl
are putting gasoline into.
-The panic-buying of gas
on the East Coast
getting so bad.
Take a look at what the
U.S. Consumer Product Safety
Commission just tweeted out,
saying...
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Just like that,
we're right back
on the world's
Do Not Travel list.
I mean, we're --
[ Laughter ]
Some people are like,
"Would it be safer
if I put the gasoline in
balloons and I swallowed them?
[ Laughter ]
And not only is there
a gas shortage,
there's also a chicken shortage.
And the company Tyson is sayin
that they're partly to blame
because the roosters
they use for breeding
have not met the demand.
[ Audience murmuring ]
The roosters heard
and were like,
"Well, the added pressure
certainly isn't helping!"
[ Laughter ]
Why do I feel like
this is going to end
with a commercial featurin
two chickens in a tub
and the announcer being like
"Ask your vet
if Rooster Cialis
is right for you"?
[ Laughter ]
And this is a tough time
for Tyson.
You hate to hear anyone having
problems with their coc--
[ Jazz Muzak playing ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some big political news.
Today, House Republicans voted
to kick Liz Cheney
out of her leadership role
Yeah, Republicans haven't
turned on someone this fas
since they tried to murder
Mike Pence.
[ Laughter ]
You could tell Dick Cheney
was upset when he offered
to take House Minority Leade
Kevin McCarthy on a hunting trip
to "talk it over."
[ Laughter ]
After the vote, Liz Cheney sai
that she doesn't want Trum
to get near the Oval Offic
ever again.
Yeah. It's not that hard,
actually.
All you have to do
is hang a sign outside
that says "Just salad."
[ Laughter ]
And this is weird --
O.J. Simpson came out on Twitter
and praised Cheney
for standing up for the truth.
She was like, "Not the
endorsement I was looking for.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, former
President Trump also weighed in,
and of course,
he kept it classy.
-New...
-I feel like that statemen
is just a Mad Lib
that Trump fills in every day.
It's like, "Blank is a bitter,
horrible human being.
Blank has no personality."
Speaking of Republicans, I saw
that over 100 Republicans
are planning to release a letter
threatening to form
a third party
if the GOP doesn't make
certain changes.
In fact, some Republicans
have already started
releasing their own statements
Check this out. First up,
Congressman Neal Dunn said..
[ Laughter ]
Next up, Congressman
Michael Guest said...
[ Laughter ]
After that,
Congressman Sam Graves said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Congressman
Dan Newhouse said...
[ Laughter ]
Congressman Pat Fallon said...
And, finally, Congressman
Guy Reschenthaler said...
It's all over the place.
Just everyone speaking out
[ Applause ]
-Wow.
-Some business news.
I read that Amazon destroyed
more than 2 million
counterfeit products last year
although I wish they did i
before I dropped 50 bucks
on my Superb Marco video game.
[ Laughter ]
-"It's me, Marco."
Superb Marco.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
His brother's Squingilli.
-Yeah, Squingilli.
-Yeah.
It's the Y-box.
You play it on the Y-box.
-Some more business news.
I saw that Natural Light
just launched its own line
of sour hard seltzer
to compete with White Claw
But White Claw's not worried
They have a new slogan...
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitates liquid pouring
-Listen to this.
A new study found
vegetarians who drink and smok
are still healthier
than meat eaters.
-Mm.
-Must be pretty annoying
having dinner with someone
who drinks and smokes
and then is like, "That
chicken breast will kill ya.
[ Laughter ]
But it's good news,
'cause vegetarians have been
feeling left out since peopl
who love cryptocurrency
became way more irritating
"No, I invested it."
"I know, I heard already.
Yeah. Good luck."
And finally, in Minnesota,
a meteorologist
was giving the forecast
when something strange
started going on
with the graphics screen
behind her. Watch this.
-57 in Marshall.
50 is the current temperatur
right now in Winona.
Ooh. That's funky!
What is going --
Ooh!
[ Laughs ]
I don't really know what's -
[ Laughter ]
-The anchor was like,
"Very funny, Jennifer.
Moving on, the mayor
has been abducted."
[ Laughter ]
That was fun.
It's almost like
when you used to win a gam
of solitaire on the computer
[ Cheering and applause ]
Everyone's talking about this.
Earlier today,
the director of the CDC
made a huge announcement.
Listen to this.
-Today,
CDC is updating our guidance
for fully vaccinated people.
Anyone who is fully vaccinated
can participate
in indoor and outdoor
activities, large or small
without wearing a mask
or physical distancing.
If you are fully vaccinated,
you can start doing the things
that you had stopped doing
because of the pandemic.
-Oh, man.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Oh, man.
Every bar in New York City
is going to feel like
St. Patrick's Day
fell on Cinco de Mayo.
Do you know what I'm saying?
I think things are
about to get crazy.
Seriously, I just got invite
to an orgy at Dr. Fauci's.
-Really?
-Yes.
Honest to God,
the next time I hear N95,
it better be in 50 years
when I'm playing Bingo.
You know what I'm saying?
Everyone is excited
about the news,
while the adults who secretl
got braces are like,
"I thought I had more time
I'm just gonna wear the mask."
Yeah, if you are
fully vaccinated,
you can go back
to doing the things
you did before the pandemic.
Well, not everything.
If you're Trump,
you still can't tweet.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yep.
That's right -- no more mask
or social distancing
for fully vaccinated people.
Tariq, you know what this means.
♪♪♪♪
[ Crunch! ]
Slow...motion...acting.
Good work, Tariq.
As if getting vaccinated
so you can return to a norma
life isn't enough incentive,
Ohio Governor Mike DeWine
came up with a pretty bold idea.
Listen to this.
-Governor Mike DeWine
is implementing
a COVID-19
vaccine incentive program
in the form
of a $1 million lottery.
Adult state residents who have
received at least one dose
will be eligible
to win the money.
A winner will be announced
each Wednesday for five weeks.
-You know some idiot
is out there like,
"Yeah, but after taxes,
it comes out to only $800,000,
so it's not really worth it.
I don't know."
Yeah, a million-dollar
vaccine lottery.
And this is fun -- instead
of drawing from a basket,
they're gonna pull
numbered cotton swabs
from someone's nose.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah. It's a theme thing.
-Wow!
-Meanwhile,
here in New York City,
Shake Shack is offering
free French fries
to vaccinated customers,
and they made the announcement
during Mayor Bill de Blasio'
briefing.
Let's see how that went.
-Show us your vaccine card
We'll get you
a free fries on us.
-Free fries
when you get vaccinated?
You're saying I can get this
These delicious fries?
If this is appealing to you,
just think of this
when you think of vaccination.
-Ugh!
-Mmm!
Vaccination. Mmm!
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh!
-Wait.
Wait.
-Oh, my God.
-Wait a minute.
-Oh! Oh!
-The sound you just heard
was every New Yorker pukin
and then packing for Ohio.
-Oh, my God.
-Wait.
-Somehow, that was real.
-That was real?
-Yeah, it happened today.
-Can I get de-vaccinated?
[ Laughter ]
-That wasn't you guys?
-Both: No.
-No, that happened.
-That was real. That happened.
-Yeah.
Somehow, de Blasio
did the impossible.
He made people want to sto
eating French fries.
I'll go get a third dose,
if he stops eating on camera
Some news out of Washington.
Yesterday, President Biden
met with the big four leader
of Congress.
And I thought some
of the things he had to sa
were pretty interesting.
-Hmm.
-Take a look.
-What?
-Wow! A muskie?
-I don't know what
he's talking about.
That wasn't all that he said
-Wow!
Really? He said more?
-Yeah, he said this.
-What is he talking about?
-Wow!
-Why doesn't anyone stop him
-He's the president.
-And, finally,
he had this to say.
-Are you serious?
One more thing?
-Yeah, listen to this.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-What?
-I don't know.
You know, it seems like
the country is going through
a different shortage every day
This week,
it started with gasoline.
And now it's something
even more serious...
-Oh!
-Dear God, will those Russia
hackers stop at nothing?
♪♪♪♪
Don't worry.
We just made a deal
with Saudi Arabia
for 10 million barrels of hone
mustard, so we're all good
[ Cheering and applause ]
Beep-beep!
The milkman will let you
honk the horn.
-Oogah!
-Yeah.
[ Car horn honks ]
Here's some more
poultry-adjacent news.
KFC is making some changes
to its packaging.
KFC is changing its packaging.
It's adding instructions
on their buckets
for reheating leftovers.
-Oh.
-Yeah. People who eat KFC
were like, "Leftovers?
I just keep going
till my fist hits cardboard.
[ Laughter ]
-Boom!
-Yeah.
-KFC is redoing their packaging.
When asked why, they said it was
on their bucket list.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Rimshot ]
What?
How -- Our show is canceled?
-Come on.
-Our show is canceled
that fast, from that?
Can I finish the monologue
It's just a couple more jokes.
We're off the air?
You got to be kidding me.
Well, I had a good run.
Love you guys.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Bucket list.
-Aha!
This is the bucket-list show
-Yeah.
Well, guys,
it's now been over a year
since we all got on Zoom,
and, yet, some people
are still getting
the hang of it,
even people on the news.
So you know what that means.
It's time for another
installment of
"Greatest Moments
in Zoom History."
Enjoy.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-My baby walked
over a mat in the --
-Did we lose Bill?
Uh-oh. Poor connection.
-What made you want to do it
-Well, my mom presented
the idea to me,
and she said that I could be
one of the first --
-I think we just lost Ty.
Ty, I think we have you back
so I'll ask the question again
What made you want to be
a part of this trial?
-And, John, in the early day
of this investigation,
what stands out to you the most?
-One-two, one-two, one-two
one-two, one-two, one-two.
One, two, three, four, five --
-We can hear you, John.
-So, let's see if
we can give Theresa a call
-Hello?!
-Theresa!
-You're upside down, girl.
Will you flip
your phone upside down?
-We can't see you.
-This way?
-One more. One more click.
-One more.
One more.
Yeah!
-That's right.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You got it.
And, finally,
it was just announced
that the "Friends" reunion
will air on HBO Max on May 27th.
[ Cheering and applause ]
May 27th?
"Could it be any closer?"
Yep, they're calling the episode
"The One that Costs Way More
than the Others."
♪♪♪♪
Happy Friday, everyone.
You guys, of course,
the entire country is so excited
that vaccinated people don't
need to wear masks anymore
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
That's right,
Americans haven't felt this good
since White Claw doubled
the amount of alcohol.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow!
-Some people aren't sure if they
can really ditch their mask.
You know, it's like being
on a work retreat
and having to do a trust fall.
It's like, "Is this okay?
Is it -- Are we --
Are we doing this?
Is this really okay?"
[ Laughter ]
It really does feel
like a new day.
This morning,
I saw two strangers
take off their masks
and "Lady and the Tramp"
a hot dog.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-I'll never forget that.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, everyone's excited
about ditching the mask,
but I promise you --
no one's happier about it
than Chuck Schumer's ears.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ee ee ee ee!
-Tch!
[ Laughter ]
-That's right, after the CDC
made their big announcement,
President Biden spoke from the
White House Rose Garden
and had to say this.
-We will rebuild our economy
reclaim our lives,
and get back to normal.
We'll laugh again,
we'll know joy again,
and we'll smile again.
[ Laughter ]
-I got to be honest --
it's nice having a president
who speaks
in Pottery Barn signs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Isn't that nice?
[ Applause ]
[ As Biden ]
We'll eat, pray, love.
[ Laughter ]
Biden then laid out the ne
rules for wearing a mask
very simply.
Take a look.
-It's...
-That's it.
[ Laughter ]
Perfect clip right there.
Biden just officially became
our first TikTok president
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Meanwhile,
with the new CDC guidance,
some businesses have dropped
their mask policies,
but I saw that others,
like Walmart,
are still requiring them.
Yep, as of now,
Walmart still requires a mask,
but, somehow,
it doesn't require pants.
[ Laughter ]
Let's switch gears here.
I saw that researchers
at the University of Arizona
have developed a cure
for bad breath in dogs.
I just feel bad for the on
scientist who was like --
[ Sniff ]
Nope.
Let's keep trying.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
pet owners were really excited
while everyone else was like
"Is this really the cure
we needed right now?
[ Laughter ]
That's what you're working on?
That's right,
the cure can eliminate the smell
for about two hours.
[ Laughter ]
I wouldn't call that a cure.
I'd call that an Altoid.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
this is very exciting --
an all-glass-enclosed elevator
that travels more
than 1,200 feet in the air
is opening this fall
in New York City.
Take a look at this thing.
[ Whoas ]
Yep.
They don't charge you to get on,
but they do charge you
to get off.
[ Laughter ]
"Get me out of here!"
Seriously, that thing's
about to kill more birds
than Captain Sully.
[ Laughter and grumbling ]
[ Isolated clapping ]
Just to mess with people,
every now and then,
they play this sound effect --
[ Glass breaks ]